so leid es mir tut aber in der in der
Tat es ist auch eine zesur hier in
Deutschland und ich bin ein großer
verfesstigter Deutschland ich liebe
schwarzrot Gold ich will mir das auch
nicht nehmen lassen von irgendwelchen
Rechten wie linken Gruppen und deswegen
freut es mich dass auch der Dachverband
makabi Deutschland von blauweiß auf
schwarzrot Gold gewechselt es aber seit
dem 7 Oktober m ist alles von meinem
Glauben in Deutschland wirklich ein
Stück weit zusammengefallen und es fällt
mir gerade schwer mich
zu beraffen und noch an das Gute zu
glauben weil das jetzt ganz ganz stark
in schwanken gerätt wenn ich hier das
sehe was auf unseren auf meinen
deutschen Straßen passassiert Land und
das geht hier mit nicht nur gegen uns
Juden es geht gegen unsere aller
Gesellschaftsform gegen alle Demokraten
die hier in Deutschland sind wir müssen
aufstehen wir müssen das erkennen dass
es bei weitem und nicht nur um die Juden
[Musik]
geht